from the director of RIPD and the writer
of Batman and Robin
comes the next installment of why a
tropes in SAT words sell to teenagers
who have already outgrown the genre what
too harsh the divergent series insurgent
return to the second best franchise
about a teenage girl revolutionary whose
name ends and is but this time the
stakes have been raised at least I think
they've been raised the egg kind of
forgot about what happened in the first
one as you're dropped into the middle of
a world so full of its own insufferable
jargon
you'll scramble to remember what the
anyone is talking about
who did what to where now Tris is back
but her hair isn't new watch as she
finds out she's not just a virgin she's
super duper special offer two virgins
some are much stronger than others you
need to find that very special way she's
what we've been looking for now
this chosen one must team up with the
other divergence dauntless and the
factionless to take on Kate Winslet's
erudite faction with the support of
candor and Amity to avenge the attack on
abnegation and you know what that's it
I'm prostrating by the bounteous measure
of an orderly circuitous vernacular in
the cinematic offering see I with the
source - after the first movie where
Tris had to pass a bunch of tests to
join a clique she'll have to pass a
bunch of tests to open a box all while
struggling to separate reality from her
nightmares simulations and simulations
within simulations you're not your
hearts as the divergent series tires of
recycling other better yaa movies and
just decides to rebuff The Matrix
instead how is this even legal Warner
Brothers you might want to jump on this
revisit all your favorite things about
the divergent franchise like shailene
woodley and I guess just shailene
woodley and psy as you put up with all
the other crap like faction
jibber-jabber
thank you for your candor
be less pg-13 sex Bloodless pg-13
violins respected older actors being
dragged into this mess promising young
actors being dragged into this mess and
Jai Courtney oh well I guess that's one
less thing to worry about in part three
at least they got something right so
strap in for two hours of teenage girl
wish-fulfillment culminating in a plot
twist where we learn our hero's entire
reality is just an elaborate test set up
by an outside Society who hey wait a
minute guys I know I said this last time
but we did this one uh no John we
haven't no you convinced me the last one
wasn't Hunger Games but this is totally
the Maze Runner no John different movie
no it's not it's the same exact story
look look at this if you're watching
this that means you've successfully
completed the maze trials if you're
watching this now our experiment has
succeeded what makes you different there
will be those among you who will
transcend the outside world wait mankind
waits for you see it's the same movie
they're different franchises John so
they're just recycling the same plot in
a cynical attempt to wring cash out of
teenagers yeah pretty much
oh well that doesn't seem right starring
dr. octo Tris four of these movies
really Titanic waste of talent Naomi
what are you doing in this movie mr.
fantastic has the best agent in
Hollywood Mekhi still five minutes of
screen time needles
and Ansel Elgort goofy run detergent
inverted okay I'm still confused what
exactly is the difference between
divergent and factionless again I'm
factionless because I don't fit into any
one faction and you're divergent because
you belong to too many nevermind sorry I
asked
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers for it is the thing this is
which now as this were then damn Daniel
back at it again with the white vans my
llama crashed my car into a cactus oh
well I'm gonna do to your face what Limp
Bizkit did to music in the late 90s one
batch to batch penny and dime yay Leo
won an Oscar